He was staring directly at me.
I stole a glance while turning my head to see bloodshot eyes staring back at me.
Hello and welcome to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Horror stories cooked to perfection with a splash of red sauce.
My name is CZ and I will be your server this
episode.
I know it's been a while since the last one,
and I am going to try to put these out more
often by doing some shorter episodes from
time to time.
This is a story I wrote called Bus Creep.
Let's dig right in.
I offered to help my friend move apartments
last night . She had rented a U-haul, so I
decided to take the bus to her house so I
didn't have to worry about parking.
That evening after work I went to the bus
stop near my apartment.
The bus was mostly empty; there were about
8-10 passengers on board.
I took one of the sideways seats near the
front.
Most of the passengers were near the front,
since there were plenty of open seats.
There was one guy sitting in the dark at the
back of the bus who I noticed when I first
sat down.
I didn't think much of it, as you can pretty
much count on there being at least one junkie
on every bus ride, I usually just try to ignore
it.
Which I did, until I heard the guy get up
and walk to the front of the bus...
Only...
Instead of getting off, he stopped right in
front of me and sat down in the seat directly
across.
My first inclination is to not make eye contact,
but I didn't have to look him in the eye to
realize...
He was staring directly at me.
I stole a glance while turning my head to
see bloodshot eyes staring back at me!
He had on one of those long rim hats like
you'd see on a pilgrim at Thanksgiving, with
two long black pony tails coming down over
both shoulders.
He had a short black trench coat and black
pants.
But his skin was pale, and rough looking,
like white sandpaper.
His messy facial hair almost constituted a
beard.
But maybe what bothered me most was his clenched
teeth.
I couldn't tell if he was really excited about
something or if the sight of my face made
him furious without reason.
I decided I wasn't going to wait to find out.
I got up and moved seats.
He turned his head and continued to stare,
so I just got on my phone and tried to block
him out.
This worked for about 5 minutes until the
guy got up again and moved into the seat across
the isle from me.
Ok, now this was starting to make me nervous.
My stop was coming soon and I was faced with
a predicament.
Chances are he wasn't going to follow me off
the bus...
But if he did, I'd be alone...
And relatively defenseless.
But if I stayed on the bus, I felt like this
dude might be on the verge of snapping.
After considering for another minute, I decided
I'd stand up unexpectedly and walk fast to
get off the bus.
Hopefully he'd be left behind if he even attempted
to follow.
My heart rate increased as we got close to
my stop, but I tried to make it look like
I'd be settled in for a while.
When my stop was called I waited...
One one-thousand, two one-thousand, three
one-thousand...
Then I hopped up and exited the bus and fast-walked
away.
I quickly heard the bus door close back behind
me.
I looked back, thinking I'd be alone, but
what I saw was the creep, standing there as
the bus pulled away, his yellowing teeth glowing
in the moonlight, that same maddening stare
plastered upon his face.
There was only one thing to do now.
Speedwalk.
I wasn't going to run unless he actually did
something threatening.
I also gave my friend a call.
*Phone ring.*
"Hey, I'm here."
I lied.
"Can you meet me at the gate?"
As I walked I made an effort not to make it
obvious that I was looking back.
I kept up the fast pace.
When I got to the first corner I snuck a look
back over my shoulder.
The dude was right on me.
If anything he was actually closer than he
was before.
He was still walking, but breathing heavily
to keep up.
I picked up my pace.
I j-walked at the next intersection to prevent
him from getting any closer, and he followed,
nearly getting hit by car to do so.
Now I was getting scared.
I moved into a jog, I was basically jogging
at this point anyway.
I heard his keys jingle behind me, signaling
that he too had started running.
I saw my friend waiting at the gate ahead
of me.
I motioned to her to go inside.
She got it.
I ran through the gate and she swung it shut
behind me, just before that haunting face
came up to the gate and stared through the
bars.
Not knowing if he'd try to hop the fence,
I ushered her inside.
After explaining that night's events to this
point, I was relieved to find out that the
garage is connected to her building, and we
wouldn't have to go outside to load the van.
There was one point where I thought I saw
the man's face again inside the building.
The door between the hallway downstairs and
the garage is made of glass, and as someone
swung it open ahead of us, I could have sworn
I'd seen the man from the bus in the reflection,
causing me to freeze up in the middle of the
hall.
However, when we actually looked in the parking
garage it was completely empty.
At the time, it was easy to chalk this up
to my paranoia, me just jumping at shadows.
But what happened later that night has sort
of thrown that into question.
It took a couple hours to fill up the U-Haul,
and by the time we pulled out, it was getting
pretty late.
I sat in the front passenger's seat as she
drove.
She used her clicker to open the sliding iron
gate.
No sign of anyone on the street.
As we pulled out, I looked left and right
down the sidewalk.
Thankfully, the street seemed empty, perhaps
the guy had gone home.
The rest of the night went pretty smoothly.
We unloaded the boxes at her new place, celebrated
the completion of the move with a glass of
wine, and I was on my way.
My friend offered me a ride home.
I wanted to take it, but knowing that they
charge by the mile for U-Hauls, and knowing
that we were nowhere near where the incident
with the bus creep had taken place, I opted
to take the bus again.
We were actually closer to where I live now,
so I didn't mind.
And so, I was on my way.
I'll admit that the idea of that man's stare
hadn't left my mind as I walked alone to the
bus stop, but logically I didn't expect to
see anything, and I didn't run into anyone
on the way to the bus stop.
When I boarded the bus, I made sure there
were no shady looking characters hiding in
the back, and once again, took one of the
sideways facing seats near the front.
That's when maybe the most haunting part of
any of this became a reality.
Looking out the window, I saw the same man
from before, staring at me from beside the
bus, standing right at the bus stop where
I'd been standing moments before.
I have no idea how he could have tracked me
from her old apartment to her new apartment
and now to the bus stop miles away from where
this all started.
It seemed like slow motion while the bus driver
closed the doors, and the man made no attempt
to board, his trenchcoat blowing in the wind
as he stared me all the way out of sight.
That was the last I saw of the bus creep in
person.
But since then, I've woken up three times
tonight.
Each time, his face was piercing into my nightmares.
I don't think I'll be taking the bus tomorrow.
Thanks for listening to Al Dente Creepypasta.
Your total today comes out to $1.75 but if
you like this video I'll waive that fee and
give you everything you just listened to absolutely
free.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I'll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.